estos son los lotes de la vacuna de
fisher y bryant que llegaron al hospital
de la universidad de croydon en el sur
de londres en reino unido- inicia su
campaña de inmunización este martes las
dosis están almacenadas en congeladores
a 70 grados bajo cero y serán
distribuidas cuando sea apropiado el
hospital está haciendo las revisiones
finales para poder implementar el
programa de vacunación para nuestros
grupos prioritarios y grades la vacuna
que está almacenada en paquetes
congelados que contienen 900 75 dosis
cada uno puede ser trasladada cuatro
veces y dura sólo cinco días en los
refrigeradores los primeros en recibir
el fármaco serán los residentes y
personal de hogares para personas
mayores seguidos de adultos mayores de
80 años y trabajadores sanitarios de
primera línea y las dosis estarán
disponibles en 50 hospitales se espera
que durante la primera semana 800.000
vacunas estén disponibles del total de
40 millones adquiridas por las
autoridades británicas al requerir dos
dosis
el fármaco permitirá inmunizar a 20
millones de personas en un país de 67
millones de habitantes
velocidad a la que fue aprobada en
reinounido sumada a la información falsa
que ha circulado en línea ha despertado
desconfianza de una parte de la
población hacia la vacuna
bajo esta se aplicaron los más altos
estándares de escrutinio seguridad
efectividad y calidad
no debería haber duda de que esta es una
vacuna muy segura y altamente efectiva
si sin embargo de acuerdo con medios
locales figuras como la reina isabel
segunda de 94 años y su esposo el
príncipe felipe de 99 han indicado que
recibirían el fármaco y lo comunicarían
al público